Alexis Moussine-Pouchkine: Hi, everyone.
We're back here at Devoxx
2014, and I'm here with Felipe.
Hello.
FELIPE HOFFA:
Hello, [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: We're here
to talk about big data.
You're our big data
guy, and maybe more
specifically,
BigQuery, and that is
one of the things
you were talking
about yesterday
at the conference.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, exactly.
We did a presentation
with Thomas Park
from the BigQuery team.
He's our software engineer.
And we've presented one of
the new features of BigQuery,
the user defined functions.
MALE SPEAKER: Before
we get to that,
I think that is absolutely
a very nice feature that
is coming along really well.
What is BigQuery?
FELIPE HOFFA: BigQuery
is a Google product
on the cloud that's useful
to analyze data really,
really fast.
It's zero configuration.
You just need to load
your data to be queried,
and then you can query it
in seconds using just SQL.
MALE SPEAKER: So
interactive time
is what we call it, so
don't wait for a batch
to run all night
and get a result.
So you can iterate.
That's the addictive part of
BigQuery is you can tweak it.
How do you query it?
FELIPE HOFFA: It's
just using SQL,
and the great
feature of BigQuery
is that you don't need to care
about indexing your tables.
It just runs fast.
Whatever arbitrary
query you write,
it will do full table
scans in seconds.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
So this is big data.
I don't do big data, so why
should I care about this?
I don't have big enough
data sets, right?
FELIPE HOFFA: If you have been
using tables and databases,
if you have been
writing SQL queries,
you've had
frustrations, probably.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
I think that is fair to say.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah?
So if you have ever seen a query
taking minutes or hours to run,
with BigQuery, you can take
the same time to seconds.
MALE SPEAKER: So you're saying
if I have long running SQL
queries, I'm doing big data.
I just don't know it.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
Exactly.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, great.
FELIPE HOFFA: Also,
BigQuery is awesome
if you want to share data.
If you have data that you want
to share with more people,
BigQuery has strong
access controls
that let you share the data
immediately with other people
without them needing
to set it up.
MALE SPEAKER: That's very good.
So everybody knows SQL.
Upload your data,
start querying results
in a matter of a few seconds.
That's great.
To introduce that user defined
function feature that you
mentioned to start
with, that means
there is some
limitation, probably
in SQL as a querying language.
What are those limitations?
FELIPE HOFFA: I love SQL.
It allows me to write
90%, 95% of my questions.
But sometimes it's not enough.
Sometimes you want something
more of a procedural language
to transform the
data, to analyze it,
but at the same time, you
want the power of BigQuery
to go over the full
table in seconds.
So the question is, how do
we get a procedural language
to work in the same
massive cluster
that BigQuery has
to analyze data?
That's why the
BigQuery team, Thomas,
is adding this new
feature, the user
defined functions, where
you can write in JavaScript
any arbitrary function
you would like
that runs inside the cluster
within your SQL query.
MALE SPEAKER: So
one of the things
you were able to
do with BigQuery
is run regular expressions,
I mean embed regular.
So now I could, instead
of a regular expression,
have a full JavaScript
function that's
actually computing stuff?
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
One of the examples we ran
yesterday, we were processing
logs.
Sometimes logs have
URL encoded information
or sometimes they have
[INAUDIBLE] information.
MALE SPEAKER: Data is
never clean, right?
FELIPE HOFFA: And
regular expressions
are limited in what
they can do, but if you
can have that JavaScript
filtering inside your SQL query
that cleans up your data
however you may want to do it,
it's there now.
MALE SPEAKER: So how
is this implemented?
Do you get a performance hit?
Are you still in
interactive time?
Where is this executed?
Tell us a little bit about
how this is implemented.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
one of the questions
that people ask us
is, why JavaScript?
Why did we choose that language?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, that's
also a valid question.
FELIPE HOFFA: Well, it
turns out at Google,
we also developed a very
fast JavaScript environment.
MALE SPEAKER: I think I've
heard of something called V8.
FELIPE HOFFA: V8, exactly.
So we took the
exact V8 from Chrome
and we put it inside
the BigQuery cluster,
so its node is running V8
and your JavaScript functions
run inside its node.
MALE SPEAKER: And
probably, it's worth
mentioning here that the
reason BigQuery is maybe
more than a product
but a service
is that Google does
all the heavy lifting.
We run the cluster,
we set everything up.
Obviously, it's distributed.
This is the only
way you can get.
Give us maybe an idea
of the amounts of data
that can be processed in
a matter of a few seconds,
the data you used
yesterday, for example.
FELIPE HOFFA: One of
my favorite examples
are the Wikipedia logs.
They have billions
of rows each month,
but I am able to query it during
the presentation several times
in seconds, and just keep
changing the queries to try
different stuff and
learn different.
MALE SPEAKER: And so when
you do add those user defined
functions, is the performance
getting a whole lot worse?
Are we back to--
FELIPE HOFFA: There is a
performance hit, of course.
There is communication
between processes,
but only inside one node
instead of going outside,
so it's much faster,
but we could still
run all our queries--
MALE SPEAKER: In
interactive time still.
FELIPE HOFFA:
Interactive time, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
very exciting.
When can we get
our hands on this?
Is this coming?
It's not just a prototype.
It's actually--
FELIPE HOFFA: Right now, it's
not available publicly yet,
but several people
are testing it.
If you have any
use case that would
be very nice to test
with us, just call us
and we will enable the user
defined function for you.
MALE SPEAKER: Your
name is Felipe Hoffa,
and this is the guy
you want to ping
if you want to have
early access to this.
Certainly keep an eye on
this new feature in the cloud
platform from Google
specifically in BigQuery,
user defined functions.
Thanks for your time,
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MALE SPEAKER: And
we'll see you online.
Cheers.